من داخل ميناء اسكندرون بولايه هاتاي معنا
الان مراسلنا المعتز بالله حسن
المعتز بالله كيف يمكن وصف الوضع الان في
واحده من
المناطق التي ربما توصف بانها تضررت بشكل
اكبر من غيرها تفضل
هذه هي الصوره في ميناء اسكندرون لليوم
السادس على التوالي تتواصل اعمال اخماد
الحريق الذي شب في ميناء اسكندرون شرقي
البحر الابيض المتوسط والتابع لمحافظه
هاتاي انطاكيا تعرض ميناء اسكندرون التركي
لاضرار هيكليه شديده بسبب هذا الزلزال
طبعا كما تشاهدون في صوره عشرات ان لم يكن
المئات من الحاويات انهارت الكتل التي
جمعت بها جراء هذا الزلزال الذي وقع فجر
يوم الاثنين الماضي ما ترونه هنا هو واحد
من الاضرار التي تسبب بها الزلزال لكم ان
تتخيلوا حجم الضرر الاقتصادي في هذا
المكان فقط طبعا يتم تجميع رماد هذه
الحاويات وما بقي منها وهناك محاولات
لابعاد ما يمكن ابعاده من الحاويات التي
لم تحترق حتى الان هناك مشكله قد تكون في
رافع التي موجوده للقيام
بنقل الحاويات ولكن هناك واضح محاوله
لاخماد هذا الحريق من البر والبحر ضخ
المياه ما زال مستمرا هناك ربما اكثر من
حاويه في هذا الميناء
وربما واحد من ابرز الاسئله المطروحه في
الفتره الحاليه هو متى يمكن لهذا الميناء
ان يعود لاهميته التجاريه والسؤال هل هناك
اي فكره اي توقعات عن
الاجابه على هذا السؤال
هناك واضح ان هناك اضرار كبيره في هذا
البناء المصالح التجاريه في هذا المكان هي
مصالح دوليه وعالميه وبالتالي هذا الزلزال
تسبب في ضرر كبير في هذه النقطه تحديدا
انهيار هذه الحاويات واحتراقها هناك ربما
جهود
لسنوات طويله لاشخاص قد تكون ذهبت في هذا
الحريق شركات وضعت رؤوس اموال كبيره شركات
الشحن
كل هذا القطاع هو تضرر بالفعل نستطيع من
هنا ان نرى فعلا مئات الحاويات منها منقلب
منها ما هو محترق منها ما لم يعد موجود
الا اثاره فقط على عده نقاط هناك محاوله
لاخماد الحريق اليوم السادس هو لم ينطفئ
كنت قبل قليل اشاهد محاوله اخماده من
البحر نشاهد وجود سيارات اطفاء كبيره في
المكان نجاهد وجود حاويات تحاول فصل
الاماكن المحترقه وبالتالي
محاوله حصار ومحاصره هذه الحرائق ولكن
يبدو انه لليوم السادس وحتى الان ما زال
هناك دخان ينبعث بالمكان وهناك جهود كبيره
لاطفاء هذه الحرائق واخماد هذه النيران
علنا بعد هذا يمكن ان نفكر في اجابه متى
يمكن ان يعود هذا الميناء للعمل مجددا في
النهايه المعتز بالله ايضا يعني ان الجهود
التي بذلت في الفتره الاخيره كانت هي في
محاوله استخراج اي احياء من تحت الانقاض
وكانت تركيز كله على ذلك ربما في الفتره
القادمه مع اعلان ربما انتهاء الامل رغم
ان الامل يعني بدليل انه ما زال هناك من
يعثر عليهم ولكن الارقام اقل بكثير هل
يمكن التوقع ان تكون هناك فرق انقاذ او
جهود اكبر واي مؤشر على ذلك مما شاهدت حتى
الان
في منطقتك انت في الميناء لا يوجد لصوره
لا يوجد لصوره يمكن ان تنقل حجم ما تسبب
به الزلزال اخترت هذا المكان اليوم لانه
جزء اساسي من الاضرار التي حدثت الانسان
هو له
الاولويه دوما لكن ايضا نحن نفكر بما
الزلزال هذه هذا جزء مما سيلي الزلزال
لدينا عده نقاط ربما هنا نستطيع الحديث
بها ليله مع استمرار عمليات ازاله الانقاض
ومحاوله الوصول الى العالقين هناك مشاكل
تتعلق باقامه الاشخاص الذين اخرجوا من
بيوتهم جراء الزلزال هناك عمل سيكون كبيرا
واضح على مستوى ازاله مدن باكملها واعاده
بنائها من جديد هذا ليس كلاما سهلا ان
نقوم بازاله مدن كامله هاتاي مدينه هاتاي
انطاكيا هي مدينه انطاكيا مدمره بالكامل
ولا يمكن العوده للسكني فيها باي حال من
الاحوال وبالتالي مع وصول
التي كانت في الايام الاولى لزلزال لا
تستطيع الوصول الى محافظه هاتاي ومدينه
انطاكيا بسبب تضرر الشوارع وسباق الزمن من
اجل تحسين هذه الطرق طبعا الان بات هناك
انتشار اوسع ولكن هذه الفرق ليست في
معظمها هي فرق متخصصه كل الفرق المتخصصه
هي تذهب لمواقع معينه ولكن مع انتشار
الدمار في هذا الزلزال هناك متطوعون اكثر
من الفرق يقومون بالعمل هناك خطه تعمل بها
كانت حضارتها تركيا من اجل هذه الكوارث
هذه الخطه تتالف من
مباشره فرز اكثر من 100 الف شخص من اجل
العمل في مناطق الزلازل ولكن زلزال بهذا
الاتساع وضرب اكثر من عشر المحافظات هناك
حاجه لمساعده دوليه وهذا ما رايناه عندما
طلبت تركيا منذ اليوم الاول والساعات
الاولى للزلزال ان يكون هناك مساعدات
دوليه عندما اعلنت ااا المساعده من الدرج
الانذار من الدرجه الرابعه لم يكن احد
يتخيل ان يكون حجم الضرر بهذا
الضخامه خصوصا وانه قيل ان هذا اسوا ما
شاهده العالم خلال مئه عام او المنطقه هذه
تحديدا على العموم سنظل نتابع معك المعتز
بالله احسن خلال نشراتنا القادمه شكرا
جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات عن ميناء
الاسكندرون تحديدا في مدينه هاتاي